So, now that we have seen an example of
memory ordering, let's do a memory ordering quiz. Let's
say we have a load, a store, another pair
of load and store. Let's say that all of
the loads are cache misses, so what happens is
in cycle one, we begin executing this load. And,
send it to memory. And, it's going to take 40
cycles for it to return a value. So, in cycle
1, we send the request to memory. In cycle 41,
we finally get the value, and now we have our
R1. Let's say, that we are doing stores and loads
out of order. So, although this store really cannot get
the value until cycle 41, at least. We proceed with
this load. So, in cycle 2, we send it to
memory, in cycle 42, we get the value. This store
waits for that value but this load is sent to memory
in cycle 3 and, in cycle 43, it gets the value.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
Now what happens in cycle 42, is the store
is finally done and then in cycle 43, this
store is done and in cycle 44, this cycle
is done. So, overall, we have taken 44 cycles
to do this. But we have been doing loads
prematurely as far as the stores are concerned because
if this R2 plus 4 is equal to R3
plus 0, then actually, this load should have waited.
So we decided not to be totally safe and go and then we, we are assuming that
there will be some recovery mechanism. Your task
is to figure out when is each of these
instructions sent to memory and when do we
get the result from memory and what's the final
cycle count if we do things in order? So,
if loads and stores have to happen in order